foreign
question comes from Laura in Texas my
husband and I are on baby step two with
forty five thousand dollars left to pay
off our combined income is around is
around a hundred thousand I just started
working at a side gig delivering
groceries three nights a week after our
son goes to sleep but this pace will be
debt free by next February
we live in a good area and I rarely go
to the sketchy parts of town but my mom
is but my mom worries
about my safety and I don't think she
approves of me working so much I make 55
to 90 dollars a night should I find
another science
oh Laura this gets all of my tomorrow go
John go
number one is ready to jump in your mom
doesn't get a vote I don't care what
your mom says unless she wants to write
you a forty five thousand dollar check
unless she wants to pay you to send
ninety dollars she doesn't get a vote on
approving how much you work good grief
in what part of town golly number two
that's a that's a trigger for me when
someone says oh that's a sketchy part of
town that usually means
people look different to me or the
houses are smaller or the cars aren't as
nice
those people need groceries too if
you're in an unsafe part of town usually
people use the words unsafe if you are
scared to get hurt or injured or killed
that's one thing but just because that
part of town is sketch it looks
differently than you dude go deliver in
fact deliver more you should be making
more than 90 bucks a night uh I this
just drives me crazy
you're married
you're married you have a child your mom
doesn't get a vote move on right
100 percent
oh man you know that's a
it's a way this drives me crazy the the
but seriously though Laura and anyone
out there listening there is a freedom
when you're an adult your parents do not
get to say actually Dave and I thought
about this on a segment a few shows ago
because a girl called in and she was
like yeah my parents want me to invest
instead of pay off debt or whatever it
was
and Dave's like just tell you know girl
you go do what you wanted all of this
the camera won't sit down and have a
conversation explain why I'm doing it
he's like you don't owe them anything
you know this whole thing so there's
like this balance in life when you're an
adult and your parents are still living
and you have a relationship with y'all
obviously Laura talks to her mom quite a
bit because she knows where she lives
yeah she listens to her mom of this
balance and these boundaries as an adult
to go be an adult but what is it that
keeps people Tethered to their mom's
opinion or dad's opinion it's a hundred
different things but usually it's
approval I want my mom to think I'm
doing a good job okay and that usually
comes from a legacy of moms withholding
or controlling love based on performance
okay yeah right I will give you the nod
I'll give you my blessing when you're
doing right and if you're not and it
leaves a kid always fishing for I need
that approved because kids need that
unconditional love when it's dependent
on math grades or basketball performance
or in this case
what parts of town I enter or don't
enter right then you're going to chase
it and you'll Chase it for the rest of
your life and it's when you can unhook
from that and say I'm loved because this
guy told me he's all in and I'm loved
because I got a little son who can't
wait to see me when he wakes up in the
morning and I'm gonna work bananas to
give my house peace right when you get
on a hook and plug into that and not
plug into this person who's like well I
don't know honey it's really sketchy
over there let's see there's 1994 model
cars over there and the Lexus don't go
over that ah gets me so far it gets me
so riled up man
um those people need groceries too get
over there and help out for sure it's
not that sketchy if they're paying to
get groceries delivered either they're
doing fine in the sketchy part of town
and underneath I just tries I hate that
phrase I don't think she approves of me
working I don't care I don't care yeah I
don't care now my mom still to this day
she'll say
um have you been traveling I'll say yeah
I was in Vegas here they went to Florida
for a week and then we're back in here
and she'll say now John that's you need
some rest you need to go that's a mom's
job right right but it's not about her
approval of me that's just her doing her
mom thing which I love and I say cool
Mom thanks Mom that's right that's right
and uh I I yeah it's not attached the
same emailed that to my mortgage company
they're like that's cute but we still
need our payments right so I still am
going to work right
um but she's doing her mom thing but
it's not an approval thing I just don't
like it yep yep I don't like it I hear
it here's the thing Laura
I feel this way I feel like you are
quietly looking you have started this
process of working three nights a week
after your kid's in bed and it's
exhausting
and you're going to start looking for a
couple of little reasons to make into
big reasons so you can stop doing this
and slow down paying it off don't just
hit the gas or find another job that
will get you there faster
but get this thing done get it knocked
out and for God's sake unhook from your
mom's approval you don't need it